rocket League this is the smartest idea
for video game ever it's soccer plus
fast cars put them together you got
yourself a hit I honestly don't know
much about video games my mother told me
that would give me cancer this game has
been out for three years lots of people
have made videos doing it so we're right
on time with this one I've never played
video games with the try guys it's kind
of a huge hole in our friendship and I'm
really excited to bust that nut we're
gonna do a little tutorial here
difficulty basic please I'm a basic
[ __ ] alright
gotcha hey I'm really good at driving
the straight line this turning radius is
not like my Prius is tap x2 jump you can
jump it's all I'm gonna be doing I'm
just gonna be jumping the entire time
boom one job
locating the ball I was like when you
misplace your phone sometimes you
misplace your giant ball I'm like a
regular Vin Diesel in here I'm pretty
sure if I were in the Fast and Furious
crew they would disown me at this point
tutorial complete congratulations Keith
you're very bad at this game to make
things a little more interesting we've
also thrown in a little side bet the
best the worst player gonna compete
against the two people who kind of
average and then the winners get to
drive their car into a big ball and that
ball will fly into the losers disgracing
them forever
we actually haven't gotten permission to
do this yet it's probably not safe we're
gonna do it anyway we're all gonna play
strikers to see who's the best at
striking obviously this is the first
time any of us have played this game I'm
not a fool I'm gonna choose rookie Ned's
always cocky I'll probably do something
dumb like put himself on the hardest
setting difficult the rookie Pro
all-star good let's do off star I think
you Gino through the worst it's got a
chance come on here Seth hey every fiber
of my inner child is like activated
right now it's just saying screw you mom
I'm glad game sorry mom if you're
watching power slide oh yeah
I'll just be happy venting them fail the
ball the ball oh wow look at that replay
I'm sure all the internet comments say
my boy keeps your sucks well Q you suck
Zach thinks is the best driver the try
guys you know a good driver
here's the fast driver yeah when they
score never heard that one in my dating
life old former trying to beat all-star
Oh get some gets fast fast fast speed
speed speed unlisted I should not have
done all-star all right 50 percent not
bad I'm pretty sure I did the worst 0%
all-star training I'll probably do
something down mm-hmm Wow 70%
I bet Ned did a lot better than me
though right who's winning so far me
sure Wow Wow Ned must really suck back
to rookie training that's why I scored
60%
so now what I'm the best one at 70%
which is technically a d I got my buddy
30 over here so together here a hundo 15
60 so you know we're just kind of split
in the middle between the two of us
we're giving 110% today
Eugene how did you do earlier - sucks
right great I'm not that good either I
think the computer made an error let's
do this - wine go go go everybody go to
the ball go to the ball
let's go I didn't realize that what
happened so quick
I really have a new reverence for gamers
to tell them this is impossible how do
you talk and play at the same time I'm
just trying to not crash the Wow I'm on
the wall and I'm doing just fine up here
somehow no no I supported myself
Ned's life was trying to play deep in I
think that kids are last 100 Ned's wife
you're they boned that one and we should
just both playoff and oh the RAM
somebody hard Zach you've always been
good at hard ramming thank you what a
beautiful day to drive around in a
wasteland with my exploding car friend
what's that controller I'm the best
thank you very much all I want to do is
imagine 30 in your mouth right now
likes blue I really I'm just circling
around name is Keith and I would have
crusher
I'm on top of the
second that's why yeah
I buzzed correctly you know this is a
video game video this was our chance to
like kind of even the playing field
worried about it we aren't aggressive it
up oh man was just any other yeah
sometimes Ned's wife ruins your plans I
hit the boss just now by the goal
yeah no this is the chai guys as you've
never seen this before so upset wedding
anxious and each other's throats why am
I on the ceiling get off the goddamn
ceiling thank you
I don't know this is good this is intent
go keep go go I'm not a ceiling get off
the ceiling God yeah I'm plummeting like
dad I shot my load so quiet will you
call that D please
these gaming culture so some people talk
to you never inviting me I think we need
to reunite as a squad let's see how we
do together I was getting admittedly a
little a little risque with my own game
sometime you misplaced your giant ball
King I want to do is imagine 30 in your
mouth that's what videos do video games
like make you so upset here we go guys
let's get a win for the peppers payback
oh yeah right there already
Oh Jackie down the ceiling that's you oh
my god yes
I'm waiting for the I'll be forward I'm
waiting for the planner in the middle to
Center
[Applause]
we want let's get out of here I'm
excited to have Zack and Ned drive a
ball into me or maybe we'll get hurt
since you scored all the points Ned do
you think it I could like score one and
hit that car Zack you're the best driver
of the try guys can't wait for you to
miss us yeah guess so
Ned safety first Oh give me some chills
I'd together try together
[Music]
you know Ned I gotta say I appreciate
your no striving but you really carried
the team do you want to do the final
drive IPOP - let's do it
hey well you got
[Music]
you hit us once yeah yeah ready
[Music]
this is why we won I will hold on this
at the car
Wow that's cool we're getting a big ol
ball kick just in to us right from a car
does that mean if we play Halo they're
gonna shoot each other there yeah
thank-oo has the guns cool